I am a World Economic Forum young global
leader for 2012 i was sharpening the
creative industries in the philippines
through my organization the dog
Animation Studios which is a social
enterprise that promotes the creative
and after Filipino to the medium of
animation thank you i am a British
champion speller requiring comment
office of the United Kingdom studying
Monday the University of Westminster in
London so now I'm here in Puerto
Vallarta here in Mexico attending the
annual summit of the young global
leaders that same time the world
economic forum on Latin America as a
young believer Angela me the creative
industries because I believe you believe
it's an opportunity to express
themselves and at the same time
entrepreneurship in order to alleviate
poverty in the world so in the medium of
animation computer gaming and comics
will be able to express ourselves within
a generation and at the same time update
are taking culture 18 holer and express
it to the world I believe that we can
also be shared to other countries baby
teaching animation and entrepreneurship
at the same time because the you needs
an outlet where the game champion the
expression so as a younger believe a
that's the position that I am
undertaking thank you very much